Here is why the movie quote is still playing.
Thus far in RecordSoundsViewController,
we have a function called audioRecorderDidFinishRecording.
And inside this function, what we are doing is saving the recordedAudio.
By the way, we are tracking two things about the audio.
Its file path and its title.
Now, even though we are saving the recorded audio,
we're not quite passing it from the first scene to the second.
If you want to play the sounds in the second U controller,
we need to pass this data to the second scene.
Let's do that next.
Now to do this, I will go back to RecordSoundsViewController and
introduce you to another function that we inherit from UIViewController.
It's called prepareForSegue.
And as I start to type it, Xcode autocompletes it for me.
This function, prepareForSegue, it gets called just before a segue is about to
be performed and therefore is a great place to pass any data.
In here, I will add an if statement and
check to see if my segue identifier is stopRecording.
Now this type of a check becomes really important when we
have multiple segues connected to the same ViewController.
All right, to pass data to this second ViewController,
we somehow need a way to access it in code.
And I can do that with this line.
Here I created a constant called playSoundsVC, and then defined its
appropriate type, and then used segue's destinationViewController property
to get a handle on the second ViewController in our app.
I also use the as keyword in Swift to convert this destinationViewController to
the correct type we are expecting, which is PlaySoundsViewController.
Okay, so now that we have a way to access playSoundsViewController in code,
let's think about how we are going to pass data to it.
We can get our data from this sender parameter.
Remember that sender is the object that initiated the segue,
which in our case was recordedAudio.
So I can write a line of code like this to retrieve the data.
So now I just need to pass this data to playSoundsViewController.
But wait, this guy, playSoundsViewController,
it doesn't really have a way of receiving any data just yet, does it?
So to fix this, what I will do is go to playSoundsViewController from
the navigator, and create a new variable called receivedAudio.
Now this variable is of type, RecordedAudio.
This was the new class we created.
Now if you go back to prepareForSegue, I can pass the data in this manner.
I can say playSoundsViewController.receivedAudio.
This is the new variable we created in playSoundsViewController.
This is now equal to data.
Cool, let's run this project.
All right, let me record something.
Is the app working now?
Let me play the sound.
>> My momma always said life was like a box of chocolates.
>> Hm.
The app is still playing a movie quote.
Care to guess why that is happening?
Enter your response in this box.